si vous voulez le voir il sera la
brasserie qui fait l'ange sur le
boulevard
il sera dans un quart d'heure
tu vas chanter
ta mère était fier ça je t'apprends tu
as parlé moins un peu
on n'emploie jamais il sent que dans le
trouble de cette première rencontre
votre pea d'oublier tout dire un certain
nombre de jours ce assez importante
il s'agit de rock et certaines affaires
et comme je suis je m'occupe les siens
et moi j'ai bientôt revoir ce concept là
tout le temps
ça c'est mon père ton grand père dans
son bar de la place clichy
étaient légaux non
si vous n'avez pas suivi sur bienvenue
jour en jour
je vais te rendre ton mec sur la
cassette
oui je suivais
si j'avais pas fais tu serais pas là